here's what would happen if Jupiter and
Uranus collided first Uranus would have
to Elbow its way through some of
Jupiter's 80 moons but they wouldn't
stand a chance of coming between the
planet and its path as Uranus approached
Jupiter head on and they came in contact
both planets atmospheres would compress
now instead of merging into one they
both remain somewhat intact but have
many of their gases thrown off into
space so after this epic encounter we'd
still be left with eight planets in the
solar system though these two would look
a little bit different if Jupiter lost
its atmospheric gases Saturn would
become the biggest planet in the solar
system because